o esta misión artemis junto a las
próximas planeadas buscan poner de nuevo
al hombre en la luna Por qué se está
considerando histórico el aparente éxito
de esta primera Misión y de qué servirán
en el futuro
bien es extremadamente importante porque
es el primer experiencia de los nuevos
modelos de cohetes estos obviamente a
veces la gente pregunta por qué no se
hizo una réplica de las Apolo porque son
muy viejas hubo que rehacer todo
modernizar computadoras todo el sistema
interno todo esto ha salido perfecto no
ha habido ni una sola falla en todas las
misiones Así que es un éxito enorme para
la NASA otra de las preguntas que quizás
se hace mucha gente es porque la
humanidad no ha vuelto a la luna en todo
este tiempo
bueno La pregunta es muy buena y es
fácil La respuesta es muy caro realmente
cada misión Apolo si vamos a la a las
primeras misiones no estas que son un
poco más baratas las misiones Apolo
estaban en orden de hoy alrededor de
200.000 millones de dólares cada una
Entonces era demasiado caro y ya lo que
se podía hacer con las apolos ya se
había hecho Entonces no tenía Sentido
seguir yendo a la luna ahora con nueva
tecnología nuevo impulso se está
pensando pero ya es como para una
especie de colonización ir a la luna
volver regresar en el
2024-2025 pero ya con vista de hacer una
base lunar para el Salto al planeta
Marte si precisamente de eso le quería
hablar porque Más allá del simbolismo de
volver a poner el pie en nuestro
satélite que se busca exactamente con la
llegada a la luna de esta misión es una
misión mucho más científica quizá la
anterior tenía un ámbito más
propagandístico en medio de la Guerra
Fría
totalmente totalmente esto ya es más de
investigación de hecho mira como está
planificada que es una primer misión no
tripulada una segunda ante mis dos que
es tripulada y la tercera ya planificada
para bajar para descender nuevamente en
la luna todo esto es planificando a
largo plazo el viaje a Marte porque
imagínate una cosa es ir a la luna que
está acá nomás comparativamente con un
viaje a Marte que puede durar meses o
años entonces hay que probar toda
tecnología nueva todas cosas que se van
a empezar a utilizar en estas misiones